digitale
werden also der digital
technik
tali sierung digitale
ist anders gesagt vielmehr die
kulturelle seite der digitalisierung
wir sehen dass das digitale eingang
finden uns an alltag jeder von uns hat
smartphones jeder von uns hört
elektronische musik jeder von uns nutzt
google wenn es darum geht suchergebnisse
zu bekommen oder vorhersagen zu bekommen
das heißt die digitalität ist die
digitale struktur wie sie sich in
unserem alltag in der lebenswelt
wiederfindet und da gibt es bestimmt
besonderheiten der digitalität zum
beispiel der hypertext über sexualität
bedeutet dass wir nicht mehr sukzessiv
denken schritt für schritt sind dass wir
vernetzt denken digitalität verändert
auch und die weise wie wir denken wir
denken immer mehr im kontext wie waren
es auch bei wikipedia sieht dass wir ein
blau unterlegten klink haben auf dem
klicken von dem begriff auf den nächsten
besuch kommen und am ende ein ganzes
netz von begriffen und verarbeitet haben
das ist auch ein modus der digitalität
der unser denken betrifft
social media ist sicherlich ein
die form der digitalität die soziale
netzwerk facebook verändern die art und
weise wie wir kommunizieren wie wir uns
mit freunden unterhalten die wir
interagieren
wichtig ist hierbei zu sagen dass der
direkte bezug das direkte sehen der
andere person hier nicht mehr so eine
große rolle spielt wir machen diese
kommunikation von haus aus wir sitzen in
der regel vor dem bildschirm oder wir
kommunizieren über smartphones aber wir
sehen uns nur selten in der wirklichkeit
das heißt es wird eine neue form der
wirklichkeit der realität erzeugt das
kann dazu führen dass wir viel
unverbindlicher kommunizieren dass wir
dem anderen nicht mehr rechenschaft
schuldig sind dass wir einfach schnell
auch mal auf eine frage nicht
beantworten können und dann sagen können
um ein handy ist irgendwie abgestürzt
und ich habe es nicht mehr gesehen als
es wird schwieriger die kommunikation
die gefahr ist auch die dass es
oberflächlicher wird das muss man ganz
klar sagen
auf der anderen seite bietet die
digitale kommunikation auch viele
vorteile man kann zum beispiel den
anderen immer direkt informieren aus dem
urlaub in die neuesten informationen
zukommen lassen
auch mit kleineren videos man kann seine
unmittelbaren eindrücke und emotionen
direkt dem anderen mitteilen
und das geht auf die traditionelle weise
nicht so einfach wenn ich da in einem
anderen land bin dann braucht es erst
viel zeit bis ich wieder zurück bin und
dann meine freundin mein freund wieder
treffen in das erzähle das heißt es ist
eine viel größere form der
unmittelbarkeit aber eben auch eine
größere form der unverbindlichkeit die
damit einher geht ein weiterer
kritischer punkt den ich sehe ist der
dass man über die sozialen medien der
regel nur positive eindrücke schildert
dass man in der regel nur eine
möglichkeit hat einen gleich zugeben
einen daumen hoch und viele kritische
punkte unangenehme tatsachen werden
nicht mehr so häufig angesprochen das
heißt es wird auch eine scheinwelt
tendenziell erzeugt die vielleicht nicht
so sehr der wirklichkeit entspricht und
dass sich also ein sehr problematischen
punkt bei den digitalen netzwerken an
ein anderer wichtiger punkt der
digitalität ist das was sich die inter
objektivität nennen möchte inter
objektivität im gegensatz zu inter
subjektivität in der subjektivität
bedeutet dass verschiedene subjekte
menschen personen miteinander
interagieren kommunizieren sprachlich
verständigen inter objektivität meint
nun dass auch dinge gegenstände
miteinander in kontakt treten
das kann dadurch gestehen dass sie
miteinander über das internet vernetzt
werden
das als zum beispiel der kühlschrank
weiß dass ich jetzt hunger habe oder
dass ein anderes gerät wie mein
smartphone plötzlich mit dem fernseher
integriert und eine eigene ein eigenes
netzwerk erstellen was auf meine
bedürfnisse abgestimmt ist und was in
nervösen weise meine gedanken lesen kann
so dass ich gar nicht mehr aktiv
entscheiden muss was ich jetzt will
sondern dass dieses internet der dinge
wie es auch heißt meine bedürfnisse von
selbst befriedigt und das könnte man
unter dem aspekt den begriff der inter
objektivität zu mir